professor alan dershowitz joins us
tonight professor Dershowitz it just to
start with a factual question are you
doing the bidding of Vladimir Putin of
course not I hate Vladimir Putin I hate
what he stands for
I hate tyranny anywhere in the world I'm
not doing the bidding of Donald Trump I
oppose Donald Trump's immigration
policies his approach to Charlottesville
and when I have an opportunity I tell
him that I am making the same arguments
about civil liberties I've made for 50
years and that I would be making if
Hillary Clinton had been elected
president and people were trying to
impeach her but at a you know people
talk about parties as if that's
something serious I don't care about
parties I'm invited to too many but at a
party this week on Martha's Vineyard a
woman said if Dershowitz were here
tonight I'd stab him through the heart
this is a Martha's Vineyard woman saying
she would stab me through the heart
another Martha's Vineyard our professor
at MIT professor Nicholas Negroponte who
has previously said he wished there were
no New York Times and that people only
got the news that represented their own
personal worldview so that they wouldn't
hear opposing points of view the same
guy who said soon there'll be a pill
that you can swallow and you'll learn
French overnight so you won't have to go
through the process of learning French
he's leading the campaign to try to get
other people to shun me in every way and
not to engage with me now they're losing
because the vast majority of people even
in Martha's Vineyard and in Chilmark
can't stand people who try to stop
speech and try to stop debate so it's
backfiring but the other point that's
very important is they did this to try
to hurt me but the end result is they're
helping Donald Trump they are
strengthening Donald Trump's hands the
people who try to shun me are giving
Donald Trump and his base an argument
about what the radicals are doing I have
one point to correct from what you said
I don't think what you're describing is
a liberal phenomenon I'm a liberal I
think it's a hard left radical
phenomenon I think liberals still
support free speech liberals still
support due process but
Democratic Party and the left has been
taken over by radicals who have no
interest in due process there like
Negroponte they only want their truth to
prevail they don't want any dissent they
don't want any argument is happening in
university campuses and when you have
professors like Negroponte giving the
students the lesson it's okay not to
engage not to talk to people you
disagree with
it's a terrible reflection of what's
going on in the United States of America
so put aside Martha's Vineyard put aside
clambakes and cocktail parties and put
aside what morning Joe was saying by the
way I challenged Morning Joe to have me
on the show when he mocks me so that I
can respond it's easy and kind of unfair
to attack somebody and then not give him
an opportunity to respond let's see if
he has the guts to put me on his show so
that I can tell his view is the truth
well nobody wants to engage and that's
that's the point you've been making over
and over I think an valiantly so that
it's not a question of people
disagreeing with each other it's a
question of one side trying to shut down
the other and prevent it from expressing
an alternative view I agree with that
and that is so bad for America and it's
so bad for young people to see the
examples that Professor Negroponte II
and others are giving we know the truth
capital T we don't need to hear any
dissenting points of view it's okay if
you just hear my point of view that's an
American totally professor thank you for
that I really appreciate it thank you